[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon, everybody.
I'm Jane Kamensky.
I'm the director of the
Schlesinger Library.
I want to welcome you on behalf
of the Radcliffe Institute
and Schlesinger, one
of its major programs,
on this, the first big
public event of Schlesinger's
75th anniversary year.
So we've actually invited
you to a birthday party
and there will be plenty of food
at the reception afterwards.
We're taking in this
75th anniversary
year a year-long look
back at our origins,
at the journey we've taken since
1943, at how far we've come,
and especially taking
stock and thinking
about new directions in future.
Calling the year 2018
our 75th anniversary
actually looks to
Schlesinger Library's second
of three foundings.
The first was the
collection that
served what was initially called
the Harvard Annex and then
later Radcliffe College
in the late 19th century.
But the anniversary we're
celebrating this year,
dating to 1943 in the middle
of the Second World War
some 23 years after American
women won the right to vote,
was the moment when the
Radcliffe alumna Maude Wood
Park, class of '98,
donated a large collection
of suffrage-related
material to create
what was called the Woman's
Rights Collection at Radcliffe
College.
This was a big
collection for its time.
It included 30 cartons
of manuscripts,
more than 300 books
and periodicals,
some assorted objects,
including possibly the suffrage
wagon that our photographs
show pulling up
to Longfellow Hall on Women's
Equality Day, August 26,
of 1943.
That's the anniversary of the
passage of the 19th Amendment
through the final state.
The Woman's Rights
Collection was that year
given a proverbial
room of its own,
which was a small padlocked
space in Longfellow Hall
now part of Harvard's
Graduate School of Education.
The first year for
which we have records
of the use of the
Women's Rights Collection
is 1949 and seven researchers
used it that year.
So here we are, 7 and
1/2 decades later.
Schlesinger houses more than
4,000 manuscript collections
and 130,000 books-- a number
that grows every day--
enough to fill three
capacious vaults on site
and much more in Harvard's
remote depository.
We are a vibrant living
library, building
on strengths like the
June Jordan collection
that came to us 15 years ago and
provides the genesis of today's
event, and building
on those strengths
to strike out in
complementary directions
as well as to break new ground.
We will break new
ground literally
at the end of this
anniversary year, late
next fall, when we thoroughly
renovate our main building
to improve our public
learning and work spaces.
And we break new
ground intellectually
with acquisitions,
like one you might
have read about last week,
the papers of Angela Davis.
[APPLAUSE]
Our work in the library is
meticulous and detailed,
so just to give you
a sense of scale,
the Angela Davis papers
are over 150 cartons--
nearly half the size of that
whole founding collection--
and it'll take nearly two
years of full-time staff work
to sort, describe,
preserve, stabilize,
and ready Angela Davis'
papers for researchers.
Our work, in other words,
is staff-intensive.
The depth of training that
our curators, archivists,
processors, staff leaders,
and reference librarians
have is known throughout
the industry and is,
among other things,
I think, one of
our key competitive
advantages in the world
of special collections.
There are a lot of
Schlesinger staff here today,
and if I could ask that you
would stand up so that we can
applaud what you do, please.
[APPLAUSE]
Our work is also
expensive and many of you
here today number among
our supporters, for which I
want to applaud you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
The acquisition of the
Angela Davis papers
is important not only because
of Davis' iconic qualities
but also because of the ways
that they reflect the library's
strategic priorities
to diversify
the collections by
race and ethnicity
and also by ideology and
political commitments,
with Angela being one of
the people who has broken
new ground intellectually and
politically and in her activism
and move the rest of
the world forward.
Before I turn over the
introduction to today's event
to my colleague, Kenvi Phillips,
Schlesinger's inaugural curator
for race and ethnicity,
let me call your attention
to a couple of other
upcoming events
that connect with
our anniversary year
and with the Radcliffe
Institute's broader
commitment to support the study
of women, gender, and society.
So on the back
table, you will see
a card that looks like this.
It's for our 75th anniversary
exhibit in Schlesinger's lobby
gallery, 75 Objects Telling
75 Stories About 75 Years.
You'll also see
a card that looks
like this that shows you all
of our Schlesinger events
for this anniversary year,
except for one that we
scrambled together so
quickly that it didn't make
the card, which is an event this
coming Monday night called Me
Too: Truths and Consequences
that Brings Harvard Faculty
Expertise to Bear on this
Fast-Moving Hot-Button Moment
and Movement.
Later, in the spring, on
April 5th and 6th, a Thursday
and a Friday, will be
our annual Radcliffe
Institute Gender
Conference, this year
in connection with the
Institute's citizenship year.
Its title is Who Belongs:
Global Citizenship and Gender
in the 21st Century, to which
I think June Jordan would
have wanted to go.
So with that, I will
turn it over to Kenvi
and welcome you to
the celebration.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- I don't-- good evening,
morning, afternoon.
I don't know what
this time of day is.
As Jane said-- thank you, Jane--
I am Kenvi Phillips.
I am the curator for race and
ethnicity at the Schlesinger
Library here and I
want to welcome you
to this wonderful evening
that we're about to have--
evening full of poetry,
commentary, and conversation
that we've planned for you
to celebrate the living
legacy of June Jordan.
And there are lots of
things that I need to do,
so please bear with me.
There are several
people that I want
to acknowledge who were
very instrumental in making
this day happen for us.
And chiefly and first
is Dr. Joshua Bennett,
who I will give you a full
bio when the panelists come up
as he will be moderating the
first portion of the evening.
Joshua led, Alicia
followed, Jane Kamensky
was a strong member
of the committee that
organized this panel,
and then, of course, I
sat there with them.
Before our panelists today,
I'm going to introduce you
all in no particular order.
I don't know if you
want to come up?
Yeah, come on up, because I
want to get out of the way
so we can start
this conversation.
I'll start with who's first,
which is Imani Perry, who
is the Hughes and Rogers
Professor of African-American
Studies at Princeton University.
She's affiliated with programs
in law and public affairs
and gender and sexual studies.
She's the author of More
Beautiful and More Terrible:
The Embrace and Transcendence of
Racial Inequality in the United
States, and Profits of the
Hood: Politics and Poetics
in Hip Hop, as well as
numerous other titles and one
that she's most
recently published
about centering around The Negro
National Anthem, Lift Every
Voice and Sing, which she told
me is really exciting so I
can't wait to read it.
Solmaz Sharif was born
to Iranian parents,
holds degrees from
UC Berkeley, where
she studied and taught under
June Jordan, and June Jordan's
Poetry for the People
in [? AND ?] at New York
University.
She's received
many awards and has
been a fellow at Stegner Fellow
and is currently a lecturer
at Stanford University.
Mariame Kaba is an organizer,
educator, and curator
who is active in numerous
social movements for prison
abolition, racial, gender,
and transformative justice.
She is the founder and
director of Project NIA,
a grassroots organization
with a vision
to end youth incarceration,
and co-founder
of numerous organizations,
including the Chicago Freedom
School of Love and
Protect, and most recently,
Served and Punished.
And then Joshua, our
organizer extraordinaire,
is the author of The
Sobbing School, which
was the national poetry
series, selection
and finalist for the
NAACP image award,
and being propertied once
myself, blackness and the end
of man, which is forthcoming.
He is a junior fellow at the
Society of Fellows at Harvard
University and he is the
director of the June Jordan
fellowship program at
the Center for Justice
at Columbia University.
And this, I should
say, is the second part
of a two-part program
that Joshua largely
put together, where we're
celebrating June Jordan's
legacy.
And the first part happened
this fall at Columbia University
and it was an absolutely
wonderful conversation
between local poets,
activists, and scholars, much
like what we'll have tonight.
Today.
Now that we've done
that, now that you've
met everybody in the room,
let's meet the big person that's
in the room.
And I'm sure you
all know her and I'm
sure you all are very
familiar with her,
because in her
writing, she definitely
revealed who she was
to us all, but we
have to talk about the woman
who we are here to celebrate,
June Jordan.
The daughter of Jamaican-born
Mildred and Granville Jordan,
she was born in 1936 in
Harlem and died in 2002
in Berkeley, California.
In the 65 transformative
years between those two years,
she published nearly
30 books of poems,
children's literature,
political essays,
wrote a column for the
progressive, taught
at several universities,
including Yale and UC Berkeley,
which is where she established
the arts and activism, Poetry
for the People program in 1991.
An activist, she was engaged in
the struggles for civil rights,
women's rights, sexual freedom,
and against militarization,
police brutality, among the
many things she discussed.
She married, she divorced,
she loved, she had a son,
and she lived.
She observed the world
around her and wrote about it
and worked to improve it, not
simply for herself, but for all
of us.
She used her language
to give voice
to those who could not
speak for themselves.
And while she befriended
literary giants,
like Toni Morrison
and Pat Parker
and Alice Walker
and Adrian Rich,
she worked for the community.
And in the tradition of
poets and writers before her,
like Langston Hughes
and Zora Neale Hurston,
she elevated the use
of nonstandard English
and advocated for
self-awareness and acknowledging
her whole self and wanting you
to acknowledge your whole self.
Jordan refused to deny any
part of her life or experience,
not even to publish, and I
know the writers in the room
are like, yeah,
publishing is important,
but you need your whole self
and she definitely lived that.
Her words were
eloquent and urgent
and timeless and
relevant and funny
and sad and scathing
and comforting
and I encourage you
to go read her work.
Her work is widely available.
She's one of the most
widely-read prolific
and published
writers that has ever
graced us with her presence.
And also, her archives are
right next door in the library.
They're open.
We open six days a week, so.
She has this
beautifully-written essay,
if you don't read anything else,
"The Difficult Miracle of Black
Poetry in America," and
in that essay/sonnet,
she says quite a few
things that are absolutely
transformative, I found, but
among them, she sums it up
to say, "This is the difficult
miracle of black poetry
in America, that we persist.
Published or not and loved
or unloved, we persist."
So we are here
today to talk about,
to celebrate and to
continue on the legacy
of this wonderful,
wonderful woman.
This wonderful,
wonderful thinker.
To celebrate the
life and the works
of the poet, the activist,
the journalist, the scholar,
the essayist, the biographer
and novelist, librettist,
political visionary, daughter,
mother, friend, lover,
radical humanist, and still
persistent black woman, June
Jordan.
[APPLAUSE]
- My God.
What else is there to be said?
How are you all
doing this evening?
OK, we got the right
energy going already early.
Thank you so much, Kenvi, for
that beautiful introduction
to the event.
If we could actually
have one more round
of applause for Kenvi Phillips
[APPLAUSE]
The June Jordan fellowship
began as a dream in my mind
as a teenager.
The idea that we could
create a series of events
where young people
could come together,
whether they were incarcerated
or not, and create art.
And so to see this event
here, with luminaries
that I have studied and
worked alongside for so much
of the past, you know,
seven or eight years,
means a great deal.
So we're going to
jump right into it
and we're going to
decrease so the spirit can
increase because that's the
tradition I was raised in.
So we'll begin
with Solmaz Sharif.
- So I'm going to read a
short-ish talk on June,
written as a series of lessons.
"One.
I never actually
met June Jordan.
She stood once in the
fall of 2001, shortly
after 9/11, in the
beginning of my first year
at UC Berkeley on the
steps of Sproul Plaza,
reading something
into a microphone.
I was late to class.
I would see her
later, I thought.
She died before I could.
This was her first lesson.
Two.
This is incorrect.
Her first lesson to me was
in the Borders bookstore
on Westwood Boulevard, which
was the one place I could go
as a teen without explanation.
The one place my parents would
allow me to stay undisturbed
until closing.
There was an anthology
of love poetry
that I haven't been
able to find since.
In it, a poem by her
called 'Taiko Dojo,
Messages from Haruko.'
The poem is the word
'no' repeated 65 times
with varying punctuation.
I hadn't heard
Taiko drums before
and I didn't know I
was supposed to read
the poem, its exclamations
and hyphens, as percussion.
Someone was not
happy, I could tell,
but otherwise, I was troubled.
Annoyed, even.
Was this a poem?
One word again and again.
How was it enough?
I remember that poem
clearly, though,
and forget every other
one in that anthology,
including one by Octavio
Paz I found moving
enough to copy for a crush.
In her memoir,
Soldier, she writes,
quote, 'Nobody bothered me
when I was reading except
to make me eat or go to bed.
It was peaceful to
read, and sometimes, I
could feel the words
kissing my face.
I would put my nose
close to the page,
and because no one
was watching me,
sometimes I would just trip a
word from the page to my eye
to my ear to the page--
the, the, the, the.
So funny, I thought.
Such a soft, funny thing,
showing up again and again.
The.
The.'
And then, in her
posthumously-published poem,
'Thoughts of a Teenage African
Girl Standing on the Auction
Block,' June writes, 'the,
that, no, that, that, no,
the, mother, mother, that, the,
no tree, water, dirty, dirty,
no air, no, hurt me,
hurt me, no, no, no.'
Three.
A poem was a sight of pleasure
nowhere else in language.
A poem was the pleasure
available to us
in language at all
times, though denied.
Any violence against
that pleasure
would be thrown into
sharp relief in the poem.
The, that, no, that.
History could be
interrogated by article.
By preposition.
A word was a note.
She was a classically
trained pianist, after all.
A librettist, an urban planner,
a teacher, an activist,
a mother.
All were present in every poem.
A poem was irritating,
even, because it
was embarrassing
to be moved, to be
pleased, so without being
able to explain why,
to be pleased in public
in my own privacy,
this was perhaps her
first lesson to me,
though I've lost track.
Four.
Pleasure is not a word used
too often by certain critics
when they talk of June,
rarely as they do,
nor is desired, though, as her
posthumous collection tells us,
she is directed by it.
'She is,' Alice Walker writes,
'among the bravest of us,
the most outraged.
And that word,
'rage,' follows her.
Take, for example, this last
review The New York Times ever
published of June's work
of her selected essays,
Some Of Us Did Not Die, which
was titled 'Rage, Rage.'
Too often, however, Jordan
rants rather than reasons,
trading an analysis
of complex problems
for self-righteous
expressions of anger
at the injustices of the world.
Her indignant
polemical reflections
on affirmative action, black
rage, or duplicity in the White
House in Some Of Us Did
Not Die promise only
to attract the attention
of the already converted.
Jordan's untamed energy and
take-no-prisoners attitude
served her well as an activist.
They have served her less well
as an essayist,' end quote.
The reviewer offers
not one example
of such rant, such indignant
polemical reflections,
so I can't eviscerate
this reviewer's argument
as I would like.
But I point to this review
because, in the post-election
world, in this nation
that loves to be post--
loves more than anything
to hold onto the myth
of the clean break and
the unexpected surprise
rather than the
inevitable grinding
conclusions of its own
unexamined psychic and material
life, a number of
poets found themselves
in a distinctly American,
they sought, crisis.
They wanted to know where
our poets of dissent were.
They who had for years
valued negative capability,
that romantic posture of
uncertainty penned in a letter
by a 21-year-old in the
British 19th century,
and found that any naming
of something political,
even if that naming is simple
description, as one might
simply describe a
Nightingale or a Grecian urn
or any other weather
surrounding our lives,
was an obliteration to rather
than an entry to mystery.
They who still refused
to look closely
at how their criteria for a
good poem and a good nation
have lined up.
They who still refused to
see negative capability,
and thought leading to negative
capability, and action,
will ensure we will be
stuck in a cultural eternity
of hand-wringing and yes, but.
Or, as a friend put more
simply in grad school,
'you can't put the CIA or the
FBI in a poem because those
words are unpoetic.'
Well, sure, but
whose fault is that?
And sure, but what
poet of these states
did not fall for that
charade of abstraction
as profundity, as
poetic, and yet did
not seed beauty and pleasure
and felicity and sex
to ideology, nationalism,
calcification,
or any easy shelter that
would be built upon exclusion,
exclusion necessary or not?
June.
And what poet was not named by
any of these poets in crisis?
June.
And who does not have a
steady publishing house?
June.
And who did not get reviewed
much in The New York Times
after she spoke out, for
example, on Palestine?
June.
And who was removed from
Pen America's board?
June.
And who was the white man
talking about when after
reading he said, 'That black
women over there should be
burned alive in green
fire,' end quote?
June.
And whose poem included the FBI
and the CIA and South Africa
and Bedford-Stuy and
Park Avenue and American
Airline and on and on, in one
edition of Norton Anthology
of Modern Poetry, only
to have it removed
from the more recent additions?
June.
Whose poem about George
Washington Carver,
fine as it is, survived?
June.
And who is and remains
our litmus test for,
well, do you really
want a poetry of dissent
or do you want to hold
onto your faith in goodness
and greatness?
June.
Until this literary
establishment--
this American literary
can find a way to talk about
June's poetry, it is doomed.
I mean to say, every criticism
leveled against June's work
as I hear it-- that it is
too didactic, too angry, too
difficult, too direct,
too loose, too free, too
untamed, too black, too
sonorous, too big, too bi, too
complicated, points to a
national and cultural crisis
that, until addressed,
will doom us all.
Five.
June.
Quote.
'If you make my life horrible,
then when I can tell the truth,
it will be a horrible truth.
It will not sound good or
look good or, god-willing,
feel good to you, either.'
End quote.
Six.
June.
Quote.
'In the context of tragedy,
all polite behavior is a form
of self-denial.'
End quote.
Seven.
June as teacher.
I use the name 'June'
despite having not
met her because I speak to her
often, even as I write this.
It is absolutely impossible
to write all of June.
A bibliography would
be much more useful.
But briefly, we can consider
a fraction of what she did
and imagine redesign of Harlem
with Buckminster Fuller.
A children's book, a young adult
novel, a [? pre to ?] Rome.
An early era wherein
she wore skirts.
A later era wherein she ironed
even, I hear, her jeans.
Even in the middle of Nicaragua
in the middle of a revolution,
which is a place
she wrote of, as she
wrote of Lebanon, of
Palestine, of Iran.
The founding of radical teaching
programs at CUNY, teachers
and writers collective, and
finally, at UC Berkeley,
her Poetry for the
People program,
which she founded after
decades of teaching
when she found herself teaching
an African-American studies
course in literature
and a women's studies
course in literature.
And one was made up mostly
of black men and one mostly
of white women and
there was no overlap
and they were having
parallel conversations.
And she said, well, this
should be in one room.
The room she called, in
the vision of Martin Luther
King, Jr., a beloved community.
That room has been for me
the greatest lesson of all.
One.
I never met June Jordan.
Her name was on
the schedule when
I took Poetry for the People
in the spring of 2002.
She died that summer.
She never made it to her
class, though it was often
promised she might, and at the
end of the very last student
reading on the last
day, the instructor
read a poem on her behalf."
This strikes me all her
writing life in the one poem
that she chose to leave us
with, so I will read it now.
On a New Year's Eve.
"Infinity doesn't interest
me not altogether anymore.
I crawl and kneel
and grab about.
I beg and listen for what can
go away, as easily as love.
Or perish like the
children running hard
on one-way streets.
Infinity doesn't interest me.
Not anymore.
Not even repetition.
Your, my, eye, lid, or
the colorings of sunrise,
or all the sky
excitement added up
is not enough to satisfy
this lusting adulation
that I feel for your
brown arm before it moves.
Moves.
Changes up.
The temporary sacred
tails that go.
First bike ride around
the house when you first
saw a squat opossum
carry babies on her back.
Opossum up in the
persimmon tree.
You reeling toward that
natural first absurdity
with so much wonder, still
it shakes your voice.
The temporary is the sacred.
Takes me out.
And even the stars and even
the snow and even the rain
do not amount to much,
unless these things
submit to some disturbance.
Some derangement such as
when I yield myself belonging
to your unmistaken body.
And let the powerful lock up
the canyon, mountain peaks,
the hidden rivers, waterfalls,
the deep down minerals,
the coal fields, gold
fields, diamond mines.
Close by the whoring ore hot
at the center of the Earth,
spinning fast as numbers
I cannot imagine.
Let the world blot, obliterate,
remove so-called magnificence.
So-called all-mighty fathomless
and everlasting treasures.
Wealth, whatever that may be.
It is this time that matters.
It is this history I care about.
The one we make together.
Awkward.
Inconsistent as a lame cat
on the loose, or quick as
kids freed by the bell, or else
as strictly once as only life
must mean.
A once upon a time.
I have rejected
propaganda teaching me
about the beautiful.
The truly rare.
Supposedly, the soft push of
the ocean at the hushed point
of the shore.
Supposedly, the soft
push of the ocean
at the hushed point of the shore
is beautiful, for instance.
But the truly rare
can stay out there.
I have rejected
that abstraction,
that enormity unless I see
a dog walk on the beach.
A bird sees sandflies.
Or yourself approach
me, laughing out a sound
to spoil the pretty picture.
Make an uncontrolled
heart-beating memory instead.
I read the papers preaching
on that oil and oxygen,
that redwoods and the evergreen,
that trees, the waters,
and the atmosphere
compile a final listing
of the world in short supply.
But all alive and all the
lives persist, perpetual,
in jeopardy.
Persist as scarce
as every one of us.
As difficult to find or keep.
As irreplaceable.
As frail as every one of us.
And as I watch your
arm, your brown arm,
just before it moves, I know all
things are dear that disappear.
All things are dear
that disappear."
[APPLAUSE]
- Next, Imani Perry.
- Good afternoon.
- I am grateful to be here.
I met June Jordan
once at a dinner,
where some person with
extraordinary grace
and generosity sat me between--
Toni Morrison was on my left
and June Jordan was on my right
and Derek Bell was in front of
me and I was a very young woman
and thought I had died
and gone to heaven.
And the thing that
was so beautiful
about the moment for me--
it wasn't a kind of an academic
or high-brow literati occasion,
it was a dinner.
And the dialogue was,
for lack of a term
that I could translate
into standard English,
was very down-home.
And I was thinking today that
there is a direct relationship
between the difficult miracle
and the downhome genius
and that there's something
that she saw and heard
at that crossroads and that I
am grateful to have witnessed.
So I want to talk about a piece
that she wrote titled Report
from the Bahamas, 1982.
And I think generally,
there's work
to be done about the idea
of reportage-- more work
to be done about the idea of
reportage in black poetics.
The way that it is
citational of the kind
of truncated and fictionally
objective fashion of the way
official stories are told.
And then, with
their work, there's
the morphing or the explosion
or the expansion of form
that opens up language
as well as opens up
history and functions
as an invitation
to reconsider reportage through
a bricolage of documentation
that sets aside
[? dispassions ?] and fictions
of reportedly objectivity.
So in the report, she describes
traveling to the Bahamas
and staying in the Sheridan
British Colonial, and at first,
she contemplates an image
of a middle-aged black man--
this was as part of the
advertising of the hotel--
middle-aged black man in
a tuxedo who is smiling.
And he's serving white
customers while both
of his feet, his shoes,
and the bottom 10
inches of his trousers are
immersed in the salt water.
And she writes, "He is so
delighted to serve you,
he will wade into the
water to bring you
banana daiquiris while you
float," she says sarcastically.
And then she moves
from that to a message
in the room from the
Ministry of Tourism
that has this brief story
of New World history.
And it's [? sort ?] of a
flyer and the flyer traces
the thread of empire.
So it describes
waves of conquest--
Columbus, then the
American loyalists
who fled to the Bahamas in the
aftermath of the Revolutionary
War, and then the
Confederates who arrived there
after the Civil War defeat.
And she notes that legitimate
history, as it's conceived,
tracks Europeans who
barge into new territory.
And at once, though in the
citation of this flyer,
it's once a single
story of empire,
and as well, there's kind of
shards of a million stories
of place and particularity.
And she moves really
beautifully between the two
over the course of the piece.
And when she turns to
contemplate herself,
she really deals with
a vexation about how
she is situated in the world.
And so on the one hand, she
describes herself as being,
quote, "about to have a West
Indian fit over that man
standing in the water, ruining
his shoes and his pants,"
but then she compares herself
to him and talks about how,
with all of her choices--
all the choices that are
available to her in her life,
she's a rich woman.
A rich American woman who,
like the other black Americans
who are staying in the
Sheraton British Colonial
hotel, along with their
white counterparts,
have come to the
Bahamas as tourists.
And then she talks about how
they all sort of argue down
the price of handmade
goods at the straw
market, sold by women who must
sell them in order to eat.
And she says, "and
so it continues,
this weird succession
of crude intruders
that now includes
me and my brothers
and sisters from the north."
And the north, in
that moment, it's
a beautifully
ambiguous signifier.
So it has a particular
signification
of African-American
letters, right?
Of an escape to freedom.
But it's also the position
that now allows her or enables
her to function as an intruder
in a long history of intruders
in the Bahamas, right?
So on the one hand,
there's this tradition
of African-American letters of
mobility is a sign of freedom,
but this is also an
instance in which
it can operate as
a sign of becoming
part of their colonial project.
So Jordan sees all of this--
her position of relative
power, her Americaness and not
withstanding her blackness
and West Indianess--
within the relations of
exploitation and consumption.
And yet, she also notes, she has
to watch her coins on vacation.
And she comments that she
isn't white, after all.
Right?
So she has to
budget the money she
spends for this particular
kind of pleasure.
So the kind of narrative force
that drives the piece gives it
a kind of nuance that I
think is really important
and is much richer, really,
than merely observing
what we popularly call
today intersectionality,
although in a sense, the
essay is about that, right?
She is at the crossroads
of multiple identities.
But she's also talking about the
multiple forces that are acting
on people in their midst.
That are shaping each of their
[INAUDIBLE] as it relations
to power and wealth.
And she's not simply
asserting that fact,
but she's moving through
the trip in the essay
and attending to human
encounters and what fracturing
or intimacy they bear,
based upon the order
of relations and power.
And even further, she
asks throughout, what
would the conditions
be that might
make intimacy, which is the
foundation for solidarity,
possible?
So she describes the
woman who cleans her room,
a woman named Olive,
and she wonders
what sense Olive, if
she were to ask her,
would make of her decision
to stay in the Sheraton.
And in particular,
she confesses that she
has chosen to stay in this
corporate hotel, a Sheraton,
because they are
under the protection
of a multinational corporation.
She was less likely to be
harassed or attacked by men.
And she says "a
black woman seeking
refuge in a
multinational corporation
may seem like a contradiction
to some, but there you are."
And then ventriloquizes
Olive and imagines
that her response would
probably be a judgmental one,
wondering, why would
you travel this far
without your husband anyway?
Which is another
logic of protection
built inside the
constraints of the world
as it is, filled with both
patriarchy and capitalism.
And Jordan doesn't have a
clear answer to that question.
She thinks, "My rights and
my freedom and my desire
and a slew of other
New World values,
what would they sound like
to this black woman described
on the card atop of my hotel
bureau as Olive, the maid?"
And she speculates
that Olive would
have no reason to worry
about Jordan's freedoms
to choose a corporation to
stay in or to not travel
without a husband.
That she'd have no reason
to worry about them
so long as Jordan didn't
give a damn about hers.
And that's really an
instructive moment
for the reader about politics
and what kind of politics
you have.
So there's a series
of other encounters.
One is with a Jewish
novelist whose story
of dealing with her overbearing
Talmudic Scholar father
resonates with June
Jordan's own life.
Another is a story
of a relationship
with a Jewish student who's
enchantment with Yiddish
and the manner in which the
syntax of a literary deployment
of Yiddish was a way of
breaking through ghettoization,
of being captured
inside yet marginalized.
Connected with her own
love of Black English.
And then she describes it
as "resonance falls apart"
in a conversation with him
when he says he doesn't really
care about the danger to the
Federal Student Loan program
because it wouldn't affect him.
And then she notes that
the loss of that program
would jeopardize her own
son's attendance at college,
so she's an instructor.
She has an encounter with
a graduate student who
is a white woman who
says to June Jordan,
you're lucky because you have
issues that give you purpose,
like poverty and police
brutality and discrimination.
Right?
But then-- this
is important-- she
says the student who says
this describes herself
as a housewife and a mother.
In other words, nobody.
And she says she did not believe
she was a person precisely
because she had fulfilled the
traditional female functions.
So you see, she's reading these
layers through the encounters,
and as the encounters move
forward, we learn that--
and so she's recalling the past
but also in the present moment
in the Bahamas, and we learn
she's there during holy week.
And the encounters
really structurally
function like the passions
of the cross, traditionally
celebrated during holy week, but
the choreography is unreliable.
And yet as a refrain, she
places the Gospel hymn, "The Old
Rugged Cross" in the peace.
And the issue is
that-- you know,
the way that I read it is that
the Easter miracle is at risk,
she's saying, because the
suffering is not redemptive,
or if it is, it's not righteous.
And she tells this little
story about irritating a woman
at a sandwich shop
because she's ordering
so much food and the woman
is sort of like, why are you
eating food?
Because you're supposed
to be fasting because it's
Good Friday.
And the lesson for me is that--
and one that she states
quite explicitly--
is that a series of
assumptions that we
make about connection along
lines of identity categories
are wrong.
The identity categories
or even the histories
of marginalization are
insufficient grounds
for connection.
Having a common enemy
isn't enough, she says.
The substance of the encounter--
the moment of mutuality and
what might come of that--
is what matters.
And she describes it as the need
that we find between ourselves.
And the report concludes with a
story of a black South African
woman whose husband--
and they're both
political organizers
who she's been working with--
and this woman has to flee
her husband's brutality
and alcoholism.
And she has an
Irish-American woman friend
who is able to intervene and
sort of working with this woman
to provide safety.
And she refuses the
idea of this as a kind
of neat Pollyanne-ish
sort of tying things up,
look we're all the same,
because in the midst of that,
in this extraordinary moment
of connection and sharing,
she recalls the taunts of
Irish kids in her youth
calling her by slurs.
And so really what she hones
in on is the work of witnessing
and that this
Irish-American woman
was able to witness the South
African woman's experience
in a way that allows her to help
her navigate safely through it.
So I'm going to stop in a
moment, but I'll just say,
I wanted to talk about this
piece for a couple of reasons.
One is that I really appreciate
these kind of multiple vertices
of position and identity
and social reality
that she puts forth
again and again
and it's an encounter
that resonates
for me because, as a black
person having visited
the Bahamas, all kinds of
thoughts of these words
come into your mind
about class and power
and relations of domination
and exploitation.
And then she talks about the
multiplicity of who she is.
She's West Indian, she's
American, she's middle class,
she's class
insecure, she's rich,
she is a woman protected from
black men by a corporation,
she is an indecent woman
because she travels alone.
And she cautions us
against this idea
that is still trafficked
in quite a bit, if not
more now than then, of
categorical identity
tells you most of what you
need to know about struggling
together or about
whether you're privileged
or Bourgeois or
poor and oppressed.
And I also love it because she
is radically honest about how
she navigates these
relations of power,
at times to her own advantage.
That's the conundrum
that we find ourselves
in in a society
structured the way this is
and a world structured
the way it is.
And finally, from my
own work on gender,
in which I've tried to draw
the architecture of patriarchy
and the patriarch and all his
ancillary figures surrounding
him, where I try to
explore what that is,
part of what I'm also
trying to figure out
is, how do we
approach its undoing?
And we have to ask how we might
be moved towards disrupting
relations of domination
by responding
to the term I like that
Stanley Cavell uses is
the passionate utterance.
A suggestion of another way
of being with one another.
That we might move towards
a different relation--
something closer to
ethical relations--
with the first step of
being able to fully listen.
And in a sense, what June
Jordan is doing in this piece
is both listening for
impassioned utterances
and also offering one.
And perhaps most
telling in that regard
is that this story
doesn't arrive on Easter.
And she talks about it being
Good Friday but Easter doesn't
come explicitly in the piece.
The marking of time in it
remains with Good Friday--
the period of waiting and
wondering about salvation.
[APPLAUSE]
- To bring us
home, Mariame Kaba.
- So people often get
up on these occasions
and say that it's
really an honor
to be in the space
with everyone here
and they usually will then thank
the organizers of the event
for their hard work.
And then they're going to
say that they're really
thrilled to be sharing the stage
with a lustrous co-panelist who
they greatly admire.
And then they'll
say that they need
to take a moment to actually
thank the audience for showing
up in a terrible snow
storm that's about to start
and I know you all want to
get home as soon as possible,
and that's what people usually
say at times like these
and those are all true for
me, but also for me, WTF.
I cannot believe that I was
invited to speak at an event
commemorating the
legacy of June Jordan.
June Jordan, who has been
a touchstone of mine,
really, since I
first read her work
in college, which was
many, many years ago.
And so I really can't
believe that I'm here today
and I'm really grateful
to be here with all of you
to celebrate her
legacy and her life.
June Jordan loved
black people and so do
I. She was an educator and
so am I. She was an activist
and so am I. She was
an internationalist
and so am I. She was a
brilliant writer and I am not.
At all.
So bear with me.
Before I was anything,
though, I was a youth worker
and I was this when I was
15 and I am still at 46.
Youth workers teach.
We mentor, we advocate,
we counsel, we console.
Most of all, we love.
We love young people.
When I read Jordan's
essay, "Nobody
Mean More to Me than You and the
Future Life of Willie Jordan,"
the youth worker in
me recognized myself
in the now hundreds
of young people
I've taught, counseled, and
loved over the past decades.
So this brings me to Michael and
to the future life of Michael.
Michael's been shot, the
voice on the phone says.
He's alive.
He'll recover.
I breathe easier.
Temporarily relieved.
It's a reprieve.
Michael was 18 and
on borrowed time.
He reminds me regularly that
he's not long for this world.
I've heard the words
in some variations
so often that they
now pour off me
like water from a shower head.
What is the antidote
to the certainty
about one's impending death?
How does one live with
the specter of death
as a constant companion?
The certainty is a thief.
It robs me of language.
I've lost my tongue.
I want to break my silence to
say that I love him and I would
be devastated if he didn't
live until he's at least 100,
but I don't respond.
I pretend that I
don't hear the words.
I'm numb, and after all,
I can't guarantee that he
will live to become an old man.
He's young, he's
black, he's poor.
He lives on the west
side of Chicago.
So I steel myself for
bad news every morning,
and this time, it arrives.
Michael belongs to the tribe
of the young and the unmoored.
His body is passing
through and he
has no expectations of staying.
We rode on the L together once.
Michael's voice boomed
throughout the trip.
I asked him to lower it.
He looked at me for a moment
and kept loud talking.
I was embarrassed at his
display and I felt disrespected
that he ignored my request.
These are emotions that
youth workers often feel.
As soon as we got
off the L, his voice
returned to its
normal decibel level.
I asked why he spoke
so loudly on the train.
His response, I want
them uncomfortable
and they need to
know that I was here.
My anger dissipated.
I have never
forgotten his words.
They are seared in my mind.
They need to know
that I was here.
We've never spoken of what
it's like to feel not here.
In Michael's words,
I hear June Jordan's.
I will no longer
lightly walk behind
a one of you who fear me.
Be afraid.
I plan to give you reasons
for your jumpy fits
and facial tics.
I will not walk politely
on the pavements anymore.
I must become.
I must become a
menace to my enemies.
Michael is in fact
a menace to society.
A problem to be managed,
controlled, and contained
by any means necessary.
He knows it and is
expected to swallow
his rage as he is surveilled
in stores and on the streets.
As he is targeted by cops
for endless stops and frisks.
As he is repeatedly denied jobs.
As his schools are closed.
As he looks over his shoulder
dodging bullets and as he
is locked in cages
with thousands
who look just like him.
A young man who has
been behind bars
for most of his formative
years has told me
on more than one occasion
that he was always
certain his life held only
two viable possibilities--
die in the streets
or die in prison.
Jordan tells us
that most Americans
have imagined that problems
affecting black life
follow from pathogenic
attributes of black people
and not from the
malfunctions of the state.
I've been a witness to the
malfunctions of every Chicago
institution--
schools, government,
law enforcement, and more.
Malfunctions which
pile up and crush hope.
Poet and teacher,
Kevin Coval, has
written, "Every institution
in Chicago fails black youth.
Segregated and systematically
inequitable, Chicago
is a town where white kids
exist in an increasingly idyllic
new urban utopia and black and
Latino kids weave and dodge
through a war zone."
Michael has been in and out of
confinement since he was 13.
My work has meant being a
witness to the everyday damage
that incarceration does to
the future prospects of so
many people who get caught
in a system of arrest, jail,
surveillance, and re-arrest.
This cycle makes it
harder for individuals
to find and hold on to
stable housing, jobs,
and relationships.
It aggravates mental health
and substance abuse problems.
Prisons are not places
for transformation
and they are not appropriate
social service providers.
Incarceration is a
traumatic experience.
People spend years after
their release working to heal.
Michael is unhealed still.
I visit Michael in the
hospital and I hate hospitals.
He smiles wanly.
I burst into tears.
The temporary relief
I feel is quickly
replaced by dread that
can't be dislodged
in the pit of my stomach.
I worry about retaliation.
I worry that violence
begets more violence.
I worry about Michael.
This is a young man living
in exile in his own country.
His humanity is unacknowledged.
He languishes in a place
that Richard Wright
has called no man's land.
Or maybe it's the place June
Jordan called "otherwhere."
He is allowed no feelings.
He is just a threat.
All of our fears
rests on and in him.
I remember our ride on
the L and his words to me,
"They need to know
that I was here,"
and I recognize
that he is demanding
to be seen in all of his
humanity by the larger world.
Yet one constant
throughout American history
is a persistent denial
of black humanity
and a callous
disregard of back pain.
June Jordan understood
this all too well,
but she was not defeated by it.
She insisted that, by
organizing, we have the power
to overcome oppression.
I, too, believe this to be true.
She was righteously outraged.
I am, too.
As far as I know,
Michael hasn't taken part
in the ongoing movement
for black lives
protests and organizing.
His struggle is to
live day to day.
His resistance is to stay
alive and he is courageous
in his personal fight.
June talked a lot about courage.
The courage of South Africans
fighting against apartheid
and of students sitting
in to insist that Columbia
and Harvard divest from it.
She reminded us of the
truth that only evil
will collaborate with evil.
Were she alive today,
I believe that she'd
tell us that the prison
industrial complex is evil
and we must not collaborate.
We must refuse.
For me, that refusal is rooted
in an abolitionist politic.
As Dean Spade says, "We see the
abolition of policing, prisons,
jails, and detention
not strictly
as a narrow answer
to imprisonment
and the abuses that
occur within prisons
but also as a challenge to
the rule of poverty, violence,
racism, alienation, and
disconnection that we
face every day.
Abolition is the practice of
transformation in the here
and now and the everafter."
I've organized for many
years alongside young people,
so I am of course inspired by
the high school students who
are currently in the streets,
demanding a change to gun laws,
and saying that they refuse to
be used for target practice.
But their activism is not new.
We've seen young people
of color, particularly
young black and brown people,
facing down tanks, demanding
policy change, and insisting
that black lives matter
for five years now.
And we've seen their forbearers
for 50 and 100 years before.
It's been six years since
the Dream Defenders descended
on Tallahassee, Florida
to occupy the capital when
Trayvon Martin was killed almost
six years ago next Monday.
They demanded an end to racist
standard ground gun laws then.
We like to forget.
To unsee what has already
happened in this country,
particularly if the people
we need to remember and see
are of color or LGBTQ or poor
or undocumented or Muslim or,
or, or.
Sonia Sanchez encourages us to
call on our residual memories.
She reminds us that
in political struggle,
we must call for on
our ancestors who
can help us to navigate
the trials of our present.
She is speaking
about the importance
of [INAUDIBLE] in whatever form
that it might manifest for you.
Quote, "We must hear
the voices and have
the dreams of those who came
before us and we must keep them
with us in a very real sense.
This will keep us centered."
Unquote.
Aren't we blessed
the June Jordan
is one of the ancestors who we
can call on and hear her voice
to keep us centered in this
current stormy weather?
What can we hear from
her in this moment?
I think that love
is a requirement
of principled struggle, both
self-love and love of others.
That we must all do what we can.
That it is better to do
something rather than nothing.
That we have to trust
others as well as ourselves.
I often repeat the adage
that hope is a discipline.
We must practice it daily.
June's work teaches
us this truth,
and tonight, it is
my privilege to stand
with you a poem written
on September 11, 2001,
Jordan tells us.
"Resolving to work
harder than I have ever
worked for the sake of justice,
which is the only true path
to peace."
This is written several months
before she dies in 2002.
So I'm calling on all
of us to do the same.
To secure the future life
of all of the Micheals
and the Michelles in
our country and beyond.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- So hi, everybody.
Thank you all for brilliant,
beautiful, thoughtful, loving
presentations.
I wanted to ask first of
all just about teaching
June Jordan's work.
And where for you
all, teaching her
work in the contemporary
moment, where
are the moments of
surprise in the teaching?
Where are you finding that the
poems and the essays really
sort of cut across the
way many of our students
are being socialized to think
in the contemporary moment,
whether it's about identity,
which has already come up,
or whether or not the CIA
and the FBI are poetic words
or not?
Or even about temporality
and life expectation.
What they can expect
from a full life.
So I was wondering if you could
all talk about that for a bit.
- So the class where--
I teach June Jordan's
work in two classes.
One is Introduction to
African-American Studies
and the other,
though, which I guess
is the more surprising one, is
I teach a course on black women
in social policy.
And I don't know if
it's quite-- it's not--
it's surprising,
particularly for those
who major in political
science or public policy,
to get poems in a policy
class, but there's
something about the kind
of register connecting
to both the ethical questions
and the interior life
that you get in the poetry
that is not accessible to them
in the same way in the
history or the politics books,
and so it allows for
an interpretation
and an understanding
of that material that's
much richer, actually.
When you actually can be
inside the lives of people.
And so for me, it's a
real pedagogical lesson
but it's also a lesson as a
student of what kinds of work
is necessary to understand--
for us to read, for us to--
so yeah, so that's the--
- So I sometimes teach
in prisons, particularly
in juvenile detention centers
in the last few years,
and I guess it was right
after Eric Garner was killed.
I taught a class with students
at the JTDC, the Juvenile
Temporary Detention
Center, Cook County,
and we read her poem
about police violence,
which the beginning
is, "Tell me something.
What do you think would
happen if every time they
kill a black boy,
then we kill a cop?
Every time they kill a black
man, then we kill a cop.
You think the accident rate
would lower subsequently?"
And it was really something
for those young people
on the inside.
One of the young people said to
me, did they get her for that?
Like, is she OK?
Like, do you know what I mean?
Like just could not
fathom that anybody
could write those words now.
And that tells
you everything you
need to know about the
surprise and the relevancy
of those terms today and
what would have happened
had June been alive
in 2014 and had put
that poem out on the internet.
What would have
happened on Facebook
or on Twitter for those lines
to be posted by a writer today?
So I always think
about the fact that,
in some ways, how far back
we've regressed as much as we've
progressed, and again,
for young people
to be so stunned that anybody
would write these words
and not have the FBI grab
them from their house,
as many have been grabbed
in the current moment.
So I think about that a lot.
I think about the
things that people
could write in the past that
can't be written today because
of social media, frankly,
and because that is just
a different kind of thing.
You're writing it
into the ether and it
is consumed by any
number of people,
but you could have done it
before in a book that nobody
would have seen and
you could have read it
in a room with
like-minded people
who wouldn't report
you to the cops.
So I think that changes the
life of the young folks who
are organizing today very
much, and so when they see
those kinds of things,
they think to themselves,
you definitely
can't do that now.
So I think about that a lot.
- I think about--
I teach her work mostly in--
I mean, I mostly teach
creative writing workshops,
so that's where
I teach her work,
and one of the
things that continues
to be surprising to me whenever
I revisit her and teach her
is how instructive
her essays are.
So that even, for example,
"Report From the Bahamas,"
which is an argument
for a kind of connection
and the building
of connection, she
gives a very specific example
of how that was done, albeit
messily and imperfectly, by
herself between two students--
that Irish woman and the
South African student.
And how she does
not rest on the kind
of diagnostic observational
mode of writing
but is constantly
pushing into action.
A lot of her essays will break
into bullet points of here
is what I did next.
Here are the actions that
we undertook as students
organizing against something.
Here is what my breast cancer
means to me in my daily life.
And you have the sense
always of a presence that
is invested not just in
your intellect and your mind
and your curiosity
but your very life.
You know?
And so to be able to teach her
as a writer that can model that
and what it might mean to
write activism into your work
creatively without losing
sight of the emotional visceral
intelligence that's really
driving the work, I think is--
I mean, she's a rare
gift in that way
of allowing for that
conversation to unfold.
- All right.
All right.
We're going to keep going in
case anyone has questions.
The microphone is open.
So can we talk a bit more, then,
about June as an organizer?
Because here I'm thinking, too,
about Poetry for the People
and how it becomes the
embodiment of a certain kind
of philosophical vision.
That for her, the
people is capacious.
It's transethnic,
transracial, and it crosses
all these different boundaries.
And so I'm wondering
if you could each speak
a bit about sort of
the greatest lesson
that June has given
you in that regard,
in terms of how is she opening
the way that you're thinking
about the collaboration
between arts and politics
or arts and events organizing
or even arts in the classroom.
- I'll say, a thing that
stands out to me about Poetry
for the People always is,
shortly after the first Gulf
War broke out, June
apparently came to class--
the student-teacher poet class--
and dropped a translated
Quran on the table and said,
you know, Arab and
Arab-American poetry
is not being taught on this
campus and we need to teach it.
Now there are five million
ways that that conversation
could have been stopped.
One, for example, the Quran
is not to be translated.
The Quran is also
not necessarily
the book of faith for all Arabs.
You know, this move itself is so
problematic and ethically messy
and dangerous in a lot of
ways that a lot of people
would just stop and
prevent it from happening.
And so for me, the
question is always,
what is the thing
that's not happening?
How do I make that thing
happen in the classroom,
rather than wait
for the expert that
would knowingly and respectfully
educate us all on this?
Like, we acknowledge
this is a thing that
is creatively and collectively
made and we have to make it
and it's going to be
a messy enterprise.
That's one thing I
think about quite often.
And the other
thing I think about
was a very difficult
conversation and position
that she would push us in
in Poetry for the People
as I inherited it, which
was that, for example, we
had an assignment wherein
everyone in that class
had to write a poem
in Black English.
Now, first, we
studied Black English.
We studied it as a language
with certain grammatical rules.
We studied it as a
language with a history
that traces back to certain
West African languages.
It was broken down for us
rule by rule, historically.
And the argument that
she was giving us was,
either you accept that
Black English is a language
and as such should be
learned and can be learned,
or you don't.
And why is it--
on the other side of that,
why is it that some of us
are forced into a
King's English--
into that discomfort--
and never have
to experience any
comparable discomfort?
Right?
That workshop was always a mess.
Who am I in the end to workshop
somebody's poem in Black
English if it's violating
the rules as it's laid down
for me but is the Black
English that they grew up with
and they know and they speak?
Right?
So it was always a firestorm to
kind of walk into, and for me,
that sense of feeling
threatened to your core
is the sense that she constantly
pushes me toward in teaching
and in her poetry and in
the classroom and beyond.
- So June Jordan--
I mean, there's a
way in which she's
connected to the foundation
of black studies, which
was explicitly--
it's going to take me
a little bit roundabout
way to get to here.
Was explicitly
political at the outset.
That it was connected to--
at least in the terms
of higher education,
that black studies was connected
to the freedom movement.
And then there is
this transition
that happens in the '80s and
more and more intensively
in the 1990s,
where, in the quest
to seek kind of real
academic legitimacy,
that deep politicization
of black studies
was undertaken so that it wasn't
treated simply as, OK, these
are the courses we have to have
so the black kids don't take
over the president's office.
Right?
And her lesson around--
she's really refusing to take
the politics out of the work
because it is political
work, whether or not
you acknowledge it.
I mean, I think the Black
English example is perfect.
And for me, when I' teaching
Black English within an Intro
to African-American Studies
course, it winds up,
even in that instance, being
a firestorm because it is--
I mean, there is such
deep feelings of anxiety
but also conceptions of
fundamental illegitimacy
to the way black people speak
that even some black students
hold that it is--
I mean, so when you have
things like that that are case
and you know black studies
is fundamentally political.
And so for her to spend a career
embracing that as a truth,
I think it is for me
an important lesson,
not just because of my
politics but because I
want to be a rigorous
scholar and a good teacher.
And then I see the other piece--
you know, there's always--
so there's this perennial
accusation about politics
and art, and so that somehow
makes it sort of less likely
to be good art, but I also think
that what she is a testimony to
is politics as art.
So that the crafting of one's
life and the seeking of beauty
that is political work.
And so that kind of, for me,
that turning it on its head
also sort of gets
away from the kind
of set ideas of what you have
to do in the freedom struggle as
opposed to thinking
about how we can
be experimental and creative.
And so I think that's
another instance in which
what she's done as an educator.
How do you exist
in the university
with politics directed
towards liberation.
Those kinds of-- she's a model.
- Yeah, I mean, I
think picking up
on Imani's last point, which is
a lesson is organized where you
are, with the people who are the
community in which you actually
are living, and so she thought
that by organizing on campus,
which is where she spent a
hell of a lot of her time.
Organizing with students.
Alongside students.
Whether it was building
to add a defense committee
or working around the South
Africa divestment programs
and being an inspiration
to the students who took
that charge to actually put
their bodies on the line.
And her saying,
I'll be with you,
putting my body on
the line alongside,
is a really important
part of what
it means to be an organizer.
I think there is a
difference between people who
are organizers and activists.
It's like, there's actually
a big difference there.
And I think that it gets
very blurry for folks
in the current moment, but
if you're an organizer,
you're developing
leaders more than you
are the person upfront on lone
ranger wearing a blue vest.
But I'm just saying, like,
that is a real thing.
That's a real thing.
There's a difference between
being an organizer tied
to a community that
you're accountable to
and speaking for yourself
on behalf of no one else.
I think we have to be
real about those things
because it's a real struggle.
So that's one.
I think the other issue we
really have to be mindful about
is, to me, the fact
that art is absolutely
necessary to social movements.
In fact, that social
movements themselves
are a form of
collective art making.
Like, I don't think people can--
I think you have to understand
that that's the case.
And Jeff Chang said years
ago that cultural change
precedes political change.
That's right.
And what can
artists do the best?
Is work on culture and help
us be able to do that work.
It's not that-- it's so
often you see that happening.
And because the cultural
change demands imagination,
and art can do a really
good job of lifting your--
kind of lifting the ceiling
off your imagination.
To allow you to think
of things that you never
would have imagined before.
And the thing that
shifted for us in Chicago,
I was the co-lead organizer
of a campaign for reparations
for police torture
survivors, which
we won a couple of
years ago in Chicago.
The first of its kind.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
And like, how did we come
to create that campaign?
That campaign came
not from the law.
People fought for years
and years and years
to try to get the police
officers convicted.
And then when one of them
finally went to trial
and was convicted,
they got four years,
and then all these people who
had been tortured for 20 years
were left thinking, this is it?
This is what we got?
So the court doesn't
produce justice.
The court enforces the law.
That's very different.
And so we were left bereft.
People who didn't have money.
People needed their
needs to be met.
The material needs that you
need to live were unmet.
People were still
having nightmares.
There was no psychological
offering of services.
Like, these were things.
And it was through art and
an imagination of, how would
we memorialize this torture?
That Joey Mogul
wrote this ordinance
that was this
emancipatory abolitionist
document that said this is going
to be a reparations ask demand.
That's what we're
going to fight on.
We're going to fight
on this and we're
going to ask for all sorts of
stuff that's not just money.
And that was through
an art project.
So that's very, very
important, I think,
for people to be thinking
about on a regular basis.
And one of the things
about organizing
is that we're often
very reactive.
By necessity.
We have to be.
What art does is it helps you
force you to be visionary.
And that's so incredibly
necessary in organizing.
So I think that she knew those
things and tried to live them.
And didn't always live up to it.
I think was honest about that.
So I think those are
some of the things that
come to mind as I think
about, like, lessons to learn
from the work, and that
work being the art that
allows for the foundation
from which we can actually
fight and win.
- Yeah.
That's beautiful.
I think we have
our first question.
Nice.
- First of all, thank
you to everybody
who made this event possible.
Excuse me because I'm a
novice to June Jordan.
I saw this event online
and I was like, all right,
this seems like something to do.
And so, as a novice, I'm
taking all the information that
y'all are putting out.
Can you tell me what kind of--
not just a lesson,
per se, but what's
the favorite thing or aspect
characteristic about June
Jordan that you would
like to impress upon folks
like myself who are a novice to
her work and her living legacy?
So what was really
that characteristic--
or doesn't have to
be the one thing,
of course, but what
would you would
like to impress upon those
who don't know as much
but can clearly see by
Radcliffe doing this that she
did something real good.
So appreciate y'all.
- Oh, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, I mean, just for me,
she took very seriously
the voices of children.
I think that was a central
component of Jordan's ethos.
Her writing.
Her thinking that children
had their own culture.
Their own ideas.
And that part of why the world
hates children, she writes,
is that they remind us of the
vulnerability in ourselves.
And so for me, reading her
work first in grad school--
"The Future Life
of Willy Jordan"
was that first essay
that I came across--
and it just struck me
that someone would ground
so much of their thinking
in that experience--
the idea that young
people had something
valuable to contribute.
So I think that that
was my one major lesson
and that sort of
spurred my desire
to constantly be thinking of
Jordan for the rest of my life.
- It's hard to say, but I would
say her laughter, actually.
And if you could
listen to her laughter.
And also, the humor
that she brings
to her work in the most
difficult-- and it's scathing.
It's snarling.
It's tender.
It's just so dexterous
and nimble and necessary,
I think, to the work--
the very difficult work--
that she was doing and after.
- She loved black people
unapologetically and overtly
and deeply.
And that shouldn't be
surprising, but in some ways,
it is, given the landscape.
And that that actually is the
grounds out of which she has--
I mean, she has an
international politics
that moves across categories of
identity and immigration status
and location and
social position.
But that as a grounds
to me is so important
but also inspiring.
And it's one of those things
that's like a guide, right?
- I think two things for me.
I always loved her
righteous outrage.
Like, if you read her, she's
like, this is fucked up.
Do you know what I mean?
And that's, like, so refreshing.
It's not like, you
know, things are harsh
and oppression exists.
You know?
Like, it's like, this sucks.
- Yeah.
For sure.
- I really loved that and
that was what drew me to her.
Like, I think it was my
feminist philosophy professor,
Peta Tancred out
of McGill who first
introduced her writing to us.
This was the late '80s.
And we were just
all like, oh my god,
like, we totally relate to her.
And then I think
the second thing
is that she embraced
being difficult.
I mean, for black women,
when you are supposed
to make yourself small
all the time in order
not to get your head
blown off by everybody--
like literally, you're swiveling
like trying not to get shot
in all different directions,
both figuratively
and literally, I think
that she embraced that.
Like, she would just be like,
somebody would interview her
and they would say, we really
see your work as blase.
And she'd say, nope, that's
not what I was thinking.
Do you know what I mean?
Like, that ain't
it, so I don't know
what you're thinking about.
Do you know what I mean?
And like, she would
just push back
in that kind of way, which
people termed difficult
because they just don't
want you to speak back.
Do you know what I mean?
They just want you to take it.
So I love those two
things about her,
and I think if you
read more of her work--
- Which I will.
- --you totally get to it.
You're going to love
the fact that that's
like, you know, fuck this.
And it's great.
You know?
Yeah.
- Appreciate everybody.
Thank y'all.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]